ow weaving hangs pots and pans from the
ceiling that is so dumb just need to cut
my sandwich in half and oh that's gonna
leave a mark
now where are those stairs oh how dumb
forget the stupid monster the most
dangerous thing in bird boxes the second
story
hello Internet welcome to film theory
forcefully opening your eyes to the mind
scarring truths hidden in all your
favorite movies so Netflix is really
hitting out of the park recently isn't
it between the choose-your-own-adventure
movie Bandersnatch and the totally not a
quiet place ripoff bird box there's been
a lot of bin jabal theory fodder coming
out of the old and well Bandersnatch
might seem like the one that's more up
my alley
considering the video game theme and all
that it's actually third box that I want
to tackle first mostly because the movie
had one question that I think we all
want answered what the heck was the
monster takechi up bird box follows a
group of people trying to survive a
worldwide catastrophe in which people
are driven to kill themselves after they
witnessed some thing in order to survive
you have to keep your eyes shut or else
wear a blindfold leading to this iconic
imagery from the movie and all these
other really dumb bird box challenge
videos on YouTube it's a really cool
concept just like noise was the
dangerous element from a quiet place
sight is the thing that gets you killed
in Bird box but the frustrating thing
about the movie is that you never
actually get to see the monster it's
never made explicitly clear what exactly
is driving everyone to this point of
madness so that is my goal today to use
all the clues that we see and don't see
throughout the movie to rip off the
blindfold and expose the bird box
monster once and for all let's look at
what we know from the opening moments
it's made clear that when most people
see whatever it is that they're seeing
they lose control and within a few
seconds look for the nearest garbage
truck to stand in front of earning car
to hop into or paint a glass to leap
through when this effect isn't just
limited to in-person appearances dragged
in the highest stakes game of naff ever
watches security cameras seize the thing
and immediate
Knox's own block off it's important to
note though that this isn't true for
everyone about midway through the movie
we learned from Gary that there are some
people who've seen it and don't
immediately off themselves
these psychos from Northwood to mental
institution for the criminally insane
they took us outside and they forced our
eyes open so that we would have to look
at the creatures it seems like all these
people are either criminals or were
already insane prior to looking at the
thing and rather than dying there
instead left to worship it serving as
prophets trying to trick or force
everyone around them to open their eyes
and behold this thing of beauty
so beauty must be in the eyes of the
beholder since these are the images that
Gary draws of the thing after he's seen
it the other reactions we get from
people who see the thing include it's
not outright terror it's just more
confusion and lastly we can deduce that
whatever it is does have a physical form
considering that we actively see it
casting shadows and setting off a car's
proximity sensors in an early scene but
it also has limited ability to actually
interact with the world considering it
can't open doors or pull off blindfolds
itself instead relying on its devotees
to do the work for it so that's a lot of
information but where's that leave us
well the movie gives us a list of
possible explanations to test in the
form of Charlie you got world religion
mythology there's full of mentions of
demons or spirit creatures that takes on
a form of your worst fears or deepest
sadness or your greatest loss except we
know that that isn't true of the bird
box creature considering the early
responses of
those responses don't scream oh this is
my greatest fear or oh this is the worst
loss I've ever experienced or is just
like oh this is it huh so that one might
not have worked out but don't worry
charlie has a lot more hypotheses that
we can put to the test circa from
ancient Christian occult beliefs you get
the hula Jean from China
you got the poo coat from Celtic
mythology all different names but the
same thing the end of us man Charlie I
know it's the end of the world and I
know this is all for your book but
you're even more melodramatic than I am
many of the entities you just mentioned
don't mean the end of us plus you're
lumped together a lot of spiritual
things that are very different and all
very wrong for the situation that you're
currently in so let's quickly knock him
off the list one by one a kumano comes
from the Zoroastrian faith one of the
oldest religions that are still in
practice today with its origins in the
Middle East and according to the
encyclopedia of demons in world
religions and culture he's the
personification of sensual desire and
lost he corrupts your morals and is said
to cause people to sit back and watch as
evil prevails so if everyone in bird box
were busy getting their woohoo on in the
streets then maybe he'd be the one at
work here but clearly that's not the
case and therefore he is clearly not our
demon sir Gant is another one that he
mentions that is also really easy to
eliminate coming out of the Christian
occult he's known as the one who opens
all locks which directly speaks to his
demonic power the ability to open any
lock in the world this makes him a
fantastic mr. beast to get possessed by
if you're clumsy with your keys but
definitely not the culprit of a movie
where the entity that's killing everyone
is befuddled by a simple door handle
moving on the pooka is an Irish
mythological creature that shape shifts
into different animals and plays pranks
on humans like turning into a black
horse and taking people for a spooky
scary ride but beyond that it doesn't
appear to be all that violent seeing it
certainly doesn't cause immediate death
and there are plenty of stories where
the pooka actually gives good luck
another easy elimination which leaves us
with the Chinese who Li Jing and
honestly this one seemed like a good fit
at first the hua Jiang are nine-tailed
Chinese Fox spirits with the ability to
shape
often taking the form of a person's dead
relatives they're able to make people
believe the opposite of what's true like
a spirit who convinces you to take off
your blindfold and see them because
they're beautiful and they're immortal
but that immortality requires them to
consume human souls a lot of things
could really work here in the case of
bird box it seems like you can make a
solid case from being our mystery entity
except here's the rub
they can pass through walls well send
another possibility through the shredder
so Charlie the movie took a lot of shots
and missed em all maybe he should
abandon that writing project to his and
instead go back to his former job seems
like you had a lot more success there so
now it's my turn and honestly after
looking at all the various behaviors of
the bird box creature no one explanation
can truly encapsulate at all that said I
do think that we can pinpoint the two
lures that have combined to create the
apocalypse that we see in bird box for
the first let's look again at Gary's
pictures at first glance these just seem
to be a bunch of random spooky pictures
but upon closer inspection you can
definitely see some key themes emerging
first the idea of exploding eyeballs
which is his artistic representation of
the process of the pupil fracturing
every time someone sees these entities
so with those pictures eliminated as
well as the ones of just generally scary
or screaming faces this is what we're
left with a bunch of pictures of
monsters let's call them horny tentacle
face and elephant nose let's focus on
tentacle face here first it looks a lot
like Davy Jones from the Pirates of the
Caribbean or it looks a lot like a
creature that one would describe like
this quote it represented a monster a
vaguely anthropoid outline but with an
octopus like head whose face was a mass
of feelers a scaly rubbery looking body
four digits claws on hind and four feet
and long narrow wings behind it if
you're familiar with your horror history
you'll know that tentacle face belongs
to none other than the Lovecraftian
nightmare Cthulhu a name that I'm sure
we're all vaguely familiar with but
might not know a whole lot about so
let's take a minute to
about him Cthulhu created by author HP
Lovecraft in his short story the Call of
Cthulhu is what's known as a great old
one a god-like entity that came from
space and now sleeps under the oceans of
Earth waiting to be awakened but not
only does fish face fit what we see in
Gary's little art project listen to how
the creator of bird box describes his
monster there's a teacher who mentioned
that a man would go mad lose his mind if
he were to attempt to fathom infinity
became like a monstrous concept to me
all right so so at some point I started
to think of infinity or something the
human mind can't assimilate as a monster
and what if that idea was actually like
personified so on your front porch
infinity is on the porch swing outside
swinging infinity is out there and if
you opened the door mind you this
interview is from way back in 2015 from
the earliest days when his book started
to get attention and long before the
author realized that he needed to be a
bit more mysterious in the way that he
talks about his story so the monster as
he saw it in his original novel was
inspired by infinity that's interesting
considering that the main theme of the
Cthulhu Mythos is human insignificance
when confronted with the idea of
infinity look no further than the
opening lines of Call of Cthulhu which
outlines this exact premise quote the
most merciful thing in the world I think
is the inability of the human mind to
correlate all its contents we live on a
placid island of ignorance in the midst
of black seas of infinity and it was not
meant that we should voyage far end
quote now if that still doesn't sound
like it matches bird box just wait
you see in Lovecraftian stories when
humans come into contact with one of
these infinite beings like Cthulhu they
go mad their brains aren't able to
comprehend the magnitude of what they're
seeing and they literally go insane but
it also doesn't apply to all humans a
subset of people become worshipers of
the old ones just like we see a
bird box to quote from Call of Cthulhu
they worshiped so they said the great
old ones who lived ages before there
were any men who came to the young world
out of the sky someday Cthulhu would
called when the stars were ready and the
secret cult would always be waiting to
liberate him and that's just Cthulhu
Lovecraft has a whole series of monsters
in his bestiary that matched the other
drawings that were seeing elephant face
that's a lot like the design of shag
nerf on horny definitely close to the
gods servants named Knight gods so we
have creatures based on the concept of
infinity that have massive size match
Garry's drawings inspire cults of
devoted worshippers and possess faces
that literally drive people insane
monsters of the Cthulhu Mythos met
practically all of our requirements
practically you see the Cthulhu
explanation misses a few major marks
first humans are - Cthulhu what insects
are to us nothing we can't be bothered
he's too busy living his best life under
the sea alongside Aquaman and Ariel that
would explain why it shows no interest
or urgency and opening doors in bird box
but Cthulhu also wouldn't be found
chasing around a few humans on a 42 hour
boat tour it's just a waste of his and
quite frankly most of the other
Lovecraftian monsters time the bigger
issue here though is the bird box
creatures ability to harness the power
of the dead up until this point I've
been dancing around one key issue here
the fact that the entity can mimic the
appearance and voice of family members
and not just people it was responsible
for killing either in the opening
moments of the movie we meet and quickly
lose a woman named Lydia as she sees the
monster she calls out
the twist is that Lydia's mom has been
dead for five years long before this
thing started attacking earth the movie
doesn't bother to explore this but to me
this is a huge detail that's critical
for understanding the lore behind this
thing it's also critical to know that
it's not restrained to mimicking just
the dead in an effort to trick boy and
girl into removing their blindfolds the
entity mimics the voice of Mallory
our protagonist who is still very much
alive so what's happening here but
before I tell you the other half of this
theory do me a favor and remove those
blindfolds for just long enough to hit
that subscribe button we have a lot of
other cool horror movie theories headed
down the pipeline so if you've enjoyed
this one which it seems like you have
making it this far then subscribe to get
notified of when we cover ways to defeat
horror villains like we did with Michael
Myers not too long ago or predict what's
gonna happen in upcoming horror movies
like us which is a theory that should be
coming out in a couple weeks now if
you're interested do me the favor hit
subscribe it helps out the channel a lot
thank you so much and now with that out
of the way let's finish this mystery up
well a Cthulhu like Monster seems to be
the physical being that people are
seeing here where are these additional
powers and motivations coming from well
they're strong evidence to suggest that
these elements are inspired by the
rapture the event in some Christian
belief where the faithful both living
and dead are taken up to meet Christ to
use the original Bible verses
1st Thessalonians chapter 4 verse 16 and
17 quote for the Lord himself shall
descend from heaven with a shout with
the voice of the Archangel and with the
Trump of God and the dead in Christ
shall rise first then we which are alive
and remain shall be caught up together
with them in the clouds to meet the lord
in the air
consider this what if Lydia calling out
to her mom is actually seeing her dead
mother in the afterlife and if Tom
really is calling out to Mallory at the
end of the movie encouraging her to open
her eyes and join him in the afterlife
all of these Souls seem to be caught up
together just like in the rapture where
they would be encouraging others to join
if that was truly
case and you have all these worthy dead
people mixed up together like a big old
yarn ball it would be a beautiful sight
just like those left behind say that it
is despite their drawings suggesting
otherwise speaking of those left behind
why are only criminals left behind on
earth well because they didn't honor
God's commandments and don't merit going
up to heaven they're not rapture
material you could say and not only does
it explain that but this theory also
gives clarity to a detail that's easy to
overlook why these delusional prophets
insist on opening the eyes of their
victims instead of you know just killing
them I mean if the monster truly wanted
these people to just kill off the rest
of humanity why wouldn't they just do it
why resort to forcing their eyes open
it's so the victims can bear witness in
the Christian faith a lot of emphasis is
put on bearing witness to God's power
Isaiah 43 verse 10 you are my witnesses
declares the Lord and my servant whom
I've chosen that you may know and
believe me and understand that I am he
even Gary seems remorseful that he kills
off Douglas without him getting to see
the entity how about the hole not
opening doors thing revelation 3:20
behold I stand at the door and knock if
anyone hears my voice and opens the door
I will come into him and eat with him
and he with me and I hear you I totally
recognize the concern - what about
everyone taking their own lives if this
is a rapture situation isn't that a
cardinal sin of the church yeah yeah it
is absolutely however this is possibly a
rapture like situation we're talking
about maybe you rapture rules are in
effect I mean think about it
typical depictions of the event are a
bunch of bodies just kind of rising up
to the heavens but that doesn't really
make a whole lot of sense does it maybe
the real rapture is just those who are
chosen answering the call to free their
spirits like abandoning the flesh and
doing stuff like garbage truck hopping
is the fastest way to do it you may have
also noticed the odd motif of pregnancy
you see it with Mallory you see it with
Olympia
is it a coincidence then that when
referring to the day of rapture the
Bible specifically refers to it coming
on like labor pains to a pregnant woman
1st Thessalonians chapter 1 now you do
not need to have anything written to you
about times and dates brothers for you
yourselves know very well that the day
of the Lord will come like a thief in
the night when people say there is peace
and security destruction will strike
them as suddenly as labor pains come to
a pregnant woman and they will not be
able to escape it's a weird coincidence
right now obviously there's an elephant
in the room why would the blind be left
behind during a rapture scenario and
yeah the meek shall inherit the earth no
not a perfect theory like I said earlier
I don't think it's any one monster or
one religious belief happening here a
rapturing Cthulhu a literal octopus
Jesus is really the closest we can
probably get there's just a lot of weird
specifications that this thing needs to
fill and in the end it's really more
like an original creation for the
purposes of the story which you gotta
say is never a bad thing
what's people coming up with an original
thought for a change go figure and heck
at the very least my explanation of an
octopus Jesus today is way better than
what they were gonna put in the movie
yeah that veiny reptile baby was an
early version of the monster that got
cuts I got to admit for as frustrating
as not seeing the monster was not saying
the monster was a whole heck of a lot
better than that but hey that's just a
theory ah film theory and if you want to
see more horrific film Theory action
click the Box on the right to see how to
beat Michael Myers or if you want to see
something that's a bit closer to home
check out our series on salad fingers
it's the creepiest animated thing that
you're gonna see today now if you'll
excuse me I have a few more endings that
I got to get in Bandersnatch I'll see
you next week